privacy is so important and these
devices that we hold in our hand on our
wrist on our computers all have so much
private information so what does Apple
do to ensure that all of that
information stays private they just
recently came out with this campaign to
bring more awareness to more
specifically how they keep your health
data private you may have seen the
commercial that they just came out with
it's a bunch of people in a doctor's
office and then Jane Lynch's voice is
doing a voiceover publicly calling out
all of these people with all of their
health ailments in a public setting so
for me I recently had a health scare
last year and I never really thought
about all of the data that is being
collected by our Apple watch by our
phones by all of the third party things
like our blood pressure I have a
thermometer I also just recently got one
of those metabolism trackers that tracks
how food is metabolizing and all of that
stuff syncs to my phone now a lot of
it's not that precious of information
that I wouldn't probably share with all
of you already but for a lot of people
who are very proud people they do not
want their Health Data out there and
shared with the world so I love that
apple is really putting together some
documentation and promoting the fact
that all of this Health Data is safe and
secure so to talk more about health and
privacy I got a chance to chat with two
people from Apple all about this Dr
semble Desai she is Apple's vice
president of health and Katie Skinner
who is head of user privacy engineering
at Apple
so I'm obviously a huge Apple fan and
from the iPhone to the Apple watch and I
love all of the health features so how
do you guys kind of go about figuring
out what health features to put in these
devices and what most can help customers
well first of all I just want to say I'm
so happy to hear that you're a huge fan
and I'm also really happy to hear that
you're doing really well after your
health care last year thank you for
sharing that story so openly it helps so
many people so thank you for that you
know when we think about our health
features at Apple we really want to
think about how do we Empower hundreds
of millions of people to take charge of
their future and their health basically
with the phone in their pocket and a
watch on their wrist and we really want
to think about how do we democratize the
availability of health and health
information and you know we're very
early in our stages of work here at
Apple but the way we think about our
features is we really think about three
things one we want to be able to use our
technology to enable people to be
proactive about their health and think
about their health in a way that enables
them to be in charge sooner so we're not
on the receiving end of bad information
but actually trying to get ahead of
anything that's happening and we know
that focusing on being proactive is so
important when it comes to your health
we also think about our health features
um from a perspective of thinking about
three core components which is what can
we tell you that's actionable what's
scientifically based and grounded in
science and then perhaps most
importantly we think about privacy from
day one when it comes to our work and we
think about the science from day one and
also what are we going to tell you
that's going to allow you to take some
action around your health and focus on
improving it giving you some information
so you can do something with it and so
you know when you think about our health
and fitness features from the health app
to our cycle tracking experiences to
sleep stages to Mobility medications our
goal is really we want individuals to
have control over their health
information it should belong to you and
you alone at all times and we want you
to be able to use that health
information to be empowered to take
great steps to be healthy I think what's
great is the Apple watch and all of
these features you don't really need
them on a day-to-day basis until you do
so for me having that super scary Health
scare of a blood clot for me being able
to know my resting heart rate what that
normal basis is and also my blood oxygen
levels was something that I needed to be
very consistent in taking and just
knowing that I always had my Apple watch
on knowing those for me like I think
really did help me be able to take
control of my health and I think that's
what's so empowering for a lot of people
is these devices are really giving that
back to just the everyday consumer and
being able to have that information to
take to your doctors is really
incredible I love that and that's
exactly what we're trying to achieve we
want you to be in the driver's seat of
your health and be empowered to ask the
questions you need to ask you know going
through the health system is hard and
scary at times so we want to make sure
we can help you make that Journey a
little bit more a little bit easier but
all also just feel more like in the
driver's seat and empowered to say like
hey let me ask these questions because I
want to know what this information means
and what it means to my health and
there's a lot of features too that I've
never even really needed to use myself
but we were talking about the health
sharing so if I want my parents or my
grandmother to share their health vitals
with me like they can do that that's
pretty powerful so for a lot of people
though that might be scary because they
might think oh no like my data is going
to be out there so what are you guys
kind of doing to make sure that that's
protected and it's only being shared
with those who they want it to be shared
with whenever you share your health data
whether with an app or another person
it's always only with explicit
permission and so you have granular
control over what types of data you
share with apps as well as people like
loved ones that you mentioned and so
these are always available to review
manage users can change them at any
point and we really think that that
enables people to as you say trust their
device more so then then they can really
use these super power for health
features to the fullest that's awesome
yeah I think that's something that might
put a lot of people's minds at ease
especially with this new Campaign which
the commercial was really funny like I
feel like bringing attention to this in
such a comical way I think will
definitely have a lasting experience
with for a lot of people so Dr simple
you were talking about the the
scientific based data so can you talk a
little bit more about that because I
feel like that's something that's really
important as well yeah I mean when we
um when we develop Health features the
way we think about it is we want to make
sure that from the get-go we're thinking
about what is the science behind what
we're able to do and so that you know
that means a few things it means running
small studies to really understand the
feasibility of whether or not we can
achieve a certain level of performance
it means looking at the medical
literature and looking at Medical Data
to understand like if we have this piece
of information what does that tell you
about a b and c and d
it also means that we test against
ground truth so for example for our ECG
features we tested against the 12 lead
ECG which is considered the gold
standard for heart rhythms and so the
goal really is to make sure that our
performance is just as good or as close
as to just as good as what's considered
the gold standard and then the last
thing is again just going back to that
actionability we want to make sure when
we tell you something that it is
scientifically grounded in an action so
for example if you have an irregular
heart rhythm notification we want to
make sure that you can take a step to
call go and contact a physician if we're
telling you about
your cardio Fitness levels we want to
make sure that you understand what your
cardio Fitness levels are and then give
you scientifically validated information
about where you stand compared to others
we have another feature called Walking
steadiness that was actually developed
off of our Apple heart move study where
we had thousands of data points from our
participants in that study we developed
this feature and then actually what that
feature does is it tells you if your
walking steadiness is you know if you're
seeing early signs of in imbalance and
if we do we actually provide you with
scientifically validated exercises to do
to be able to start working on your
balance I mean a little known thing is
that many of us start having impact on
our balance as early as our 30s and 40s
and that can be a real key problem when
it comes to injuries earlier in life and
Falls as we get older so all important
areas that we think about as we develop
our products and features for health now
it's amazing and I love hearing the
stories of how many people have been
impacted by the Apple watch whether it's
saved their lives or being able to just
have all of that data easily accessible
so I think that must be really powerful
for a lot of you at Apple to be able to
really see that you have saved lives and
you've really made a difference so now
talking about more of the Privacy now
with this campaign the commercial was so
funny like I just love that you guys
kind of brought this comedic value to
something that is so so important
because I think sometimes people take
their privacy for granted a lot of times
they don't know what's happening with
this data so can you share how iPhone
users or Apple watch users can you share
how the third-party apps and other
people can stop sharing or like what
that whole process is to make sure that
what they are sharing is what they want
to be sharing yeah at any point you can
go and check who you're sharing with in
the health app if you go to the top
right corner you tap on your initials
and they're in the Privacy section you
can see who you're sharing with in terms
of applications and which devices and
then if you want to see which loved ones
that you're sharing with then go to the
sharing Tab and you can see right there
so obviously this is built with apple
but what about third-party apps how can
we be sure that they aren't taking our
data as well like what kind of
precautions are you guys putting in
place well I think one thing that you
can do when considering to download a
third-party app is you can check out
their nutrition label in the App Store
and that can tell you more information
about their privacy policy and what kind
of data that they collect and how that
they're using it and so any third-party
app that reads or writes data from the
health app they must comply with the
terms in the developer agreement and the
App Store guidelines and so this really
means that they can only use data from
the health kit framework for health
purposes motion purposes or Fitness and
they need to be clear to the user about
how they're going to use that data also
these this data can never be used for
advertising or similar Services it can't
be sold or disclosed advertising
platforms and so there's a lot of
protections that we have built into the
store for apps that take advantage and
build great experiences based on your
health data now how do you guys actually
decide what protections to build in well
I think that we take a look at what are
what is the threat landscape out there
what are emerging threats what are known
threats and there are also some key
principles that we take a look at
whenever we're building any privacy
feature and so we have four privacy
pillars that we always keep in mind the
first one is data minimization and this
is really about only using the data
that's really needed to power the
feature the second one is on device
processing which is trying to do as much
work on device so the data never has to
leave the device and then transparency
control making sure the user understands
who they're sharing with and can make
those changes and lastly we have
security and this is a key one because
this is what actually technically
enforces the choices that a user makes
making sure if they say that they don't
want to share data with an app anymore
that's technically stopped that's great
so I guess moving forward just to ensure
that people are protected their data is
safe like what can you do to reassure
them that everything is safe and you can
only share it with who they want to
health and Healthcare have really been
built from the beginning with privacy in
mind just to talk about how their Health
Data is treated first if the data is
sitting on their phone and the phone is
locked with a passcode Touch ID face ID
all of the health and fitness data in
the health app other than the medical
idea is encrypted and this data doesn't
leave your device so then if you choose
to sync your health data to iCloud then
it's encrypted both in transit and on
Apple servers and for users that are
running with the default on two-factor
authentication as well as a passcode all
of your health and activity data is
end-to-end encrypted and so what this
really means is that it's backed up in a
way that Apple can't read it and to tell
you maybe a little bit more about
end-to-end encryption because sometimes
that term is kind of bandied around
might be kind of confusing to some
people what it really means is that your
data is encrypted with keys that are
derived from your devices and your
divide passcode so it's really protected
by something only you know and so that
means that you and your devices can
decrypt and access your health
information but only on devices where
you're signed in with your Apple ID and
nobody else not even Apple can access
this end-to-end encrypted Health Data I
think that's one of those really key
protections paired with our control and
transparency that can really let users
feel like they're in control of what
happens to their Health Data that's
great thank you Dr simple is there
anything else that you'd like to add
that you feel that might be helpful for
people when they're kind of either
getting into a fitness journey and how
the Apple watch and apple Health and
Fitness Plus and all of these things can
help people reach their goals you know I
think the the way we think about it and
what we're excited for users to
understand and hopefully leverage this
is an important tool is that as you're
setting a goal you said it very nicely
this is information that you may come
back to every day you may come back to
it month to month but the fact that we
have something that's able to collect
you know that information in a private
and secure way and then provide you with
information that's really valuable and
actionable is is just Priceless and so
to give you some examples for example
cardio Fitness is a great measure of
your um your cardiovascular health and
um when you are able to exercise and are
working out at a good level you'll see
your cardio Fitness levels at a certain
level I for example recently had an
injury and I noticed my cardio Fitness
levels drop and I use that as one of the
metrics to work back to where I was
before so it kind of set this goal up
for me to be able to get to achieve
again and you know that means working
out with some intensity working out for
a certain amount of time and making sure
that I got back to the levels that I was
at and so that's what we really want you
to think about is like how can this data
be helpful to you to be actionable I
mean the fact that it is private and
secure is so incredibly important but
also we want to make sure that that data
is yours and yours alone for you to set
goals with
um you know it's so privacy is so
fundamental it's everything we do that
we want to do that thinking for you so
you can just really enjoy achieving and
setting goals for yourself and
interacting with that health information
in the way that you want to to empower
you to be as healthy as you can be for
sure and there's so many different types
of third-party
um
things like temperatures scales blood
pressure cuffs I just recently got one
that measures your metabolism you like
breathe inside of it so it's like all of
that stuff is just being you know
centered around your phone and the
health data and being able to share that
with your doctor if you ever need to I
think is so important and it makes it so
easy and I think for consumers and just
everyday people like this is really
letting us kind of take the power back
be able to take the health into our own
hands and really kind of you know be
able to have that information I think
we're really excited that paired with
the uh super funny commercial we also
have a health and privacy white paper
that can allow people to learn more
about what are those protections that
you're talking about
um so Dr stumble as far as privacy goes
I mean that's such a huge concern for
Health Data so how are you guys kind of
taking that at the Forefront at Apple
well we just shared with you our new
campaign and it's about Health Data
privacy specifically so when we you know
the campaign that we shared is funny and
lighthearted and happens to Star the
voice of Jane Lynch but it actually
highlights a topic that's incredibly
important to us which is you know
incredibly important to us at Apple
which is privacy and specifically Health
Data privacy and so for many of us
there's nothing more sensitive than our
health data and we've seen how critical
it is in the financial world to protect
privacy of a person's financial data
while Health Data is just as if not more
so a priority to protect and so after
all there's really nothing more
important than our health and so we
really think that people should expect
the same confidentiality from their
technology as they do from their doctors
it's so it's why privacy is so
fundamental it's everything we make and
in the health space and Beyond we create
Health features that we believe you
should decide what you want to do who
you want to share it with and have the
ability to stop sharing that at any time
and so it's really one of the reasons
that privacy Central such a central core
to the principles that I shared earlier
which is is around scientific validation
and actionability were very intentional
as you heard from Katie around the
design of our Health Products and
privacy is really a central part of
design just from the ideation phase so
from the get-go we think about it from
day one and so we think this is what it
looks like to democratize Health in the
right way and we wouldn't settle for
anything else and honestly neither
should any of you you know we're excited
to empower our users with health
information and be in control of their
health information in a private and
secure way oh that's awesome thank you
so much I mean I do feel like apple and
my Apple watch and all of this
technology really did kind of help me
not only get my health in check but also
potentially could have saved my life and
I think that that's gonna help so many
other people too and it's so great to
know that you guys do have privacy in
mind thank you guys so much for joining
me thank you so much bye see you later
bye guys thank you guys so much for
watching and a huge thank you to Dr
semble and Katie for joining me here in
this video to explain a little bit more
about how apple is taking great care of
not only our health but also ensuring
that that Health Data is private I'd
love to hear from you guys though in the
comments so be sure to leave some below
and if you haven't already be sure to
like And subscribe and hit the Bell to
be notified when I post new videos and
with that I will see you guys in the
next one